amid all of the democrats far-left
failures their refusal to admit their
mistakes or acknowledge their missteps
ask yourself what is underpinning this
obsession with doubling down on stupid
refusing to acknowledge reality and
living handcuffed inside a liberal
bubble the short answer leftism is less
of a political force trying to solve
real everyday problems and instead it is
a cult in a never-ending fight with
reality hell bent on making the world
bend to their lies all while trying to
silence and destroy anything and anyone
who dares to question the orthodoxy i
know you've heard that the cancer of
vocism is the left's new religion but
it's actually not it's their cultic
foundation a set of rules and
instructions meant to manipulate and
control now keep in mind a cult has some
basic tenets and behaviors we see not
just with the so-called progressives but
now being applied by the biden
administration itself among other
aspects including groupthink as its
foundational requirement
questions are not encouraged and even
punished followers are to worship a
group leader the cult follows and
controls all aspects of members lives
fear and paranoia are instilled to keep
followers close and trusting only of
fellow members outsiders those who
escaped and opponents are smeared and
cast as evil and dangerous and members
are monitored constantly to ensure
conformity and allegiance to the cultic
system sound familiar yeah for four
years under donald trump democrats and
their allies in the media doubled down
on the russia collusion fraud even with
evidence pointing out the lies and the
facts staring them right in the face
hysterically fueling a hoax digging in
even deeper after being disproven
pushing through a false narrative and
never letting it fall off the front page
day after day because the enemy to the
status quo had to be completely
destroyed it was the left's playbook in
action control the narrative bend the
facts and never admit you're wrong and
then there was the abolished police
insanity that everyone knew was idiotic
but that didn't stop democrats from
pandering to the most extreme elements
of their party to try and paint america
as a racist country it's led to more
crime more chaos and more unsafe streets
and we see it playing out in major
cities all across the country later in
the program we'll talk to a sheriff who
says despite the white house saying
they're helping they still have not sent
in the needed funds to address the crime
surge or what about oncovit where double
masked big city liberals meander
aimlessly around manhattan using facial
coverings as some sort of partisan
signaling exercise despite being double
vaccinated many with their boosters
while being socially distanced that's
not science that's insanity it's also a
way to condition people into having
every aspect of their daily lives
controlled by faceless bureaucratic cult
and what about young children still
being forced to suffer under masked
learning despite no science to back it
up for example
here in new york city and out in
portland oregon there are now reports of
children being forced to eat outside in
frigid temperatures in a gross display
of pandemic theater so ask yourself why
are the most restrictive oppressive
coveted restrictions being used against
the group least at risk because
if they can convince you
that only the cult knows what's best for
your children
everything else follows
and then there's resident village troll
flipper fauci who is now previewing
another shifting of the goal posts
hinting that the definition of fully
vaccinated will soon change to include
getting a booster shot now that's not
all because fauci is also even
suggesting that you check your family's
vaccine status at holiday gatherings
people should if they invite people over
their home
essentially ask and maybe require that
people show evidence that they are
vaccinated
yeah no
making sure someone has no idea what the
next day will bring or what the rules
will of life will be from one week to
the next creates confusion depression
and as the establishment called hopes
surrender ask yourself have you ever
seen so much hysteria and consternation
about who's vaccinated or who isn't as
if it's the most important identifier
about someone's existence having your
identity so intertwined with which
vaccine if you're following the new rule
or not suggestions you shun your own
family for not conforming that you judge
and condemn strangers for not doing what
you are doing
sounds a lot like a cult doesn't it but
the same pattern emerges in every single
issue just take the recent decision to
remove the thomas jefferson statue from
new york city hall now even jefferson is
too controversial and our founding
fathers too divisive to even celebrate
the founding of our republic the statue
had a place in city hall for nearly two
centuries and just like that it's gone
their message is clear
no one is safe from the wrath of those
who know best we are to worship marx
socialism hillary aoc fouchy the
democrats to prove our compliance even
the founders the flag the country and
god will be removed stored smashed
banned
burned or melted down
there is a destructive desire on the
left they destroy anything that even
remotely contradicts their worldview
they're trying to destroy history by
creating a never-ending present
devoid of the context or perspective of
history so that they can make it just
that much tougher to question their
endless efforts to reimagine what
america should stand for and remember no
amount of pandering or bending the knee
will ever be enough no amount of
submission will ever satisfy today's
extremists and the the data backs it up
for example a new poll from axios finds
that a whopping 37 percent of young
democrats wouldn't even be friends with
someone who voted for an opposing
presidential candidate contrast that to
just five percent of young republicans
71 percent of young democrats wouldn't
go on a date with someone on the
opposite side of the aisle and 41
percent wouldn't shop at a business that
expressed differing political views
exposing the extent of the left's desire
to live entirely within a partisan
ideological prism so take a step back
you see what's happening here right more
and more it's obvious that the left's
end game is to control every aspect of
our lives and to freeze out anyone who
does not fall in line and to make
everything worse along the way
wanting to monitor every move you make
letting paranoia prevail indoctrinating
our children that this is all normal and
even condemning the simple asking of
legitimate questions
it's all indicative of a cult a cult
obsessed with having a false sense of
moral superiority over everyone else and
a cult obsessed with worshiping a set of
values really it's a it's a narrative
it's an agenda that is failing over and
over again hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else